les ravages des rives du cyclone hugo
neuf morts des dizaines de blessés des
milliers de sans abris faits la
guadeloupe la plus touchée exclusif
antenne de monseigneur glem stable pour
la première fois une télévision de la
sphère du carmel d'auschwitz il est
moins intransigeant la suisse montré du
doigt elle s'interroge sur la vente yves
les stupéfiants mais les banques gèrent
aussi l'argent de la drogue
reportage la déception des peugeot ils
sont venus à paris sous fond des filets
sous les fenêtres de jacques calvet mais
le patron ne les a pas reçus
bonsoir les antilles françaises et
surtout la guadeloupe viennent de vivre
des heures terribles
le cyclone hugo malgré un nom qui évoque
la poésie ce cyclone hugo et en doute le
plus violent les ouragans de ce siècle
en tout cas pour la guadeloupe le
cyclone est passé juste au dessus
résultat des ventes de 250 km/heure neuf
morts dans les antilles dont 5 en
guadeloupe et des milliers de sans abri
alors voici les premières images
tournées par nos envoyés spéciaux qui se
sont rendus sur place aussitôt après la
catastrophe
dominique merlin agnès poirier dominique
verdeilhan éventré écrasé broyer les
cases antillaise n'ont pu faire front à
hugo ce sont les habitats précaires qui
ont subi les plus forts assauts du
cyclone ces maisons de bois ne sont plus
que des tas informe de planches plaqué
au sol par un vent de plus de 240
km/heure 3600 foyers ont été ainsi
anéantie
mais c'est pas aussi violent celle-là
des touriste belge arrivé il ya quelques
jours en guadeloupe sont restés
calfeutrés toute la nuit en attendant
l'accalmie qui est tout à fait bétonné
et on est resté pendant toute la nuit
assis sur des chaises dans la salle de
bain puisque nos pieds étaient inondés
on avait 15 cm d'eau on a eu très peur à
cause du bruit était énorme on se
calfeutrait on se boucher les oreilles
on se parlait pour pas voir trop fort
c'est effrayant effrayant ce sont plus
de dix mille personnes qui ont été
évacuées vers des écoles et autres
logements de fortune mais les sauveteurs
doivent faire face à deux difficultés
électricité et téléphone coupés manque
d'eau potable réseau routier perturbé
par des débris divers
aucune commune de l'archipel n'a été
épargné selon un bilan provisoire
hugo aurait provoqué la mort de cinq
personnes et fait plus de 80 blessées
dont 40 graves en guadeloupe transall et
hélicoptères ont acheminé sur place plus
de 50 tonnes de matériel des bâches des
citernes d'eau potable des tronçonneuses
les groupes électrogènes plus de 500
hommes ont été dépêchés en guadeloupe
alors que les antillais n'ont pas fini
de panser les plaies provoquées par hugo
un autre cyclone fait déjà parler de lui
il s'appelle iris et devrait arriver
dans les caraïbes dans les prochains
jours où est le cyclone hugo n'a pas
fini de faire des dégâts puisque il est
arrivé maintenant porto rico cet après
midi à 15 heures heure française n'est
en tout cas déjà la solidarité
s'organise un exemple voici ce que vient
de déclarer monsieur le pensec le
ministre des départements des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
juste à son arrivée à la guadeloupe il a
déclaré la guadeloupe meurtri ne sera
pas laissée seule dans cette lourde
épreuve
autre exemple de solidarité jacques
delors le président de la communauté
européenne vient d'annoncer une aide
immédiate de 9 millions de francs pour
les sinistrés de la guadeloupe
et puis à paris aussi on s'organise éric
perrin les aides
dès dimanche après-midi et se s hugo se
met en place une cinquantaine
d'associations anti yates ont contactés
afin de coordonner leurs actions en
faveur des sinistrés de guadeloupe après
avoir informé les familles inquiètes dès
les premières heures
sos hugo s'oriente désormais vers la
collecte de fonds mais aussi de biens
matériels de lot d'événements il re à la
guadeloupe à travers les sinistrés a
surtout besoin de dons matériels
ce que nous savons que le premier
problème qui épouse est actuellement
sinistré cette destruction de tout ce
qu'ils avaient donc les produits de
première nécessité dont nous aurions
besoin c'est très bon bien évidemment
des denrées non périssables des
couvertures des vêtements et surtout de
quoi reconstruire ce qu'ils avaient
comme eux comme le cas comme maison peut
dire donc c'est à dire des produits du
des matériaux c'est à dire des majeurs
de construction des clous des marteaux
détenus de ce genre là est sûre et / ou
envisagent d'organiser un grand concert
de solidarité au zénith
la magie du zouk au secours des
sinistrés oui si vous voulez aider les
sinistrés de la guadeloupe et bien voici
vous pouvez vous adresser à sos hugo
dont voici les téléphones je vous laisse
lire sur notre écran 42 43 54 70 c puis
45 09 53 34 voilà j'espère que vous avez
eu le temps de noter ses deux numéros où
vous pouvez vous adresser si vous voulez
aider les sinistrés de la guadeloupe
le reste de l'actualité maintenant
peut-être un espoir de solution dans la
sphère du carmel d'auschwitz avec cette
nouvelle prise de position de
monseigneur glem c'est la première fois
que le primat de pologne acceptent de
parler à une chaîne de télévision
cette antenne 2 il a répondu aux
questions de nos envoyés spéciaux
jacques merlino et jean corneille et
vous allez le voir monseigneur glem mais
un petit peu d'eau dans son vin si je
peux me permettre
il se montre moins intransigeant
enseigné à ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi vous avez souhaité
renégocier les accords signés à genève
y'a que j'ai remis en cause des
signatures car ce n'était pas de
véritable accord un accord suppose des
engagements ayant valeur juridique entre
bouadla s'agissait que d'une déclaration
date
sion découlant de la simple bonne belot
et des deux cartes robe que finalement
on arrive assez facilement un accord et
que le problème du carmel sera ré celui
de manière satisfaisante
deux autres d'eau peuvent negore absurde
nous sommes arrivés à une situation
absurde car d'un côté les juifs on peut
appeler ça carmélites s'empare du canton
suisse de l'autre côté les polonais
craignent que les juifs sa poterie tout
le camp dans lequel ont péri aussi des
polonais et des hommes notre nation il
voit tout cela est absurde et nous
souhaitons passer de l'émotion au
raisonnement qui d agir tranquillement
assis ni l'autre quito santé sports -
magna d'oprah zone d'or absurde
ingénieur dans une homélie vous avez dit
que les juifs avaient beaucoup de
pouvoir dans les mass media c'est une
déclaration qui nous a été beaucoup
reproché
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
exactement où la mi juillet j'étais en
france que je trouvais que la presse
française donnée de ce problème une
vision partiale
cela nous a fait du mal cette façon de
critiquer les droits des serbes vivent
tranquillement là bas c'était pour moi
la preuve qu'une influence des centres
riffs sur les mass médias les peugeot
n'ont pas obtenu ce qu'il voulait les
salariés de peugeot mulhouse sont venus
manifester à paris mais ils n'ont pas
réussi à rencontrer le patron jacques
calvet le conflit ne se résout pas la
grève continue aujourd'hui à mulhouse et
à sochaux et la csl qui est un syndicat
indépendant n'exclut pas de se joindre à
la grève
françoise joly et véronique auger ont
accompagné les grévistes de mulhouse à
paris
levée depuis l'aube et se sont entassés
dans ce train plus d'un millier dans ce
compartiment ils sont 8 25 30 ans tous
originaires du même village bull dans le
haut-rhin huit à se rendre à paris pour
la première fois de leur vie lui a
partagé la même amertume
son père y travaillent aux mines et va
du bon elle a disons les mines ça va
encore durer dix ans peut-être lors de
musis et les minerais les potages se
finit quoi que l'automobile pour est
comme si on était bien payé que
maintenant la paye c'est ça commence à
devenir dur quoi vous dire
au début on pourrait s'acheter ce qu'on
voulait on voulait bien avec la paye que
n'avait que maintenant complexe nature
il ya beaucoup de problèmes aussi un
minus et des problèmes de pression de la
hiérarchie qui vous font peur ils vous
font des menaces quoi on s'était dit
qu'on vous prenne à pas et vous
comprendre pourquoi des gens la paroisse
sainte on a pas le droit
on n'aimerait pas qu'il fasse des années
des années justement passé avoir peur
d'avoir peur les années qu'on n'a jamais
bougé quoi que bout d'un moment dit pour
y aller il faut se mouiller pour
vraiment dire que ça ne va plus
12h50 le train spécial dit 7114 arrive
en gare de l'est
ici l'accueil triomphal
mais il n'ya que des délégués syndicaux
la base j'ai talbot citroën aux
chaussons n'est pas encore prête à
rentrer dans le mouvement
les peugeot de mulhouse sont jeunes
1h30 suffira pour traverser paris
jusqu'au siège de peugeot
ici l'accueil est glacial crs grilles
fermées
les salariés du siège sont tous aux
fenêtres
une heure d'attenté et hui représentants
syndicaux seront acceptés à l'intérieur
ils ressortent au bout de cinq minutes
les mains vides
la direction refuse d'ouvrir des
négociations ce soir christian bernard
et les autres n'auront rien à dire aux
douze mille peugeot de mulhouse liège
maintenant l'on retrouve peut-être le
truand philippe delaire avec un nom
pareil on sait depuis quelque temps que
c'est un spécialiste de la cavale il
nous avait tenus en haleine cet été avec
une prise d'otage d'un gendarme près de
vichy une rocambolesque échappé à bord
d'une charrette de foin
la police ne l'avait pas retrouvé et
voici qu'en belgique près de liège donc
trois gangsters prennent en otage le
week-end dernier une famille l'un des
gangsters serait philippe delaire bruno
gex et rémy roche policiers en armes
tireurs d'élite le parquet de cette
banlieue résidentielle de liège est
bouclée dans cette maison depuis bientôt
50 heures une femme et deux fillettes 10
et 13 ans sont retenus en otage
samedi soir trois hommes font irruption
le père de la famille guy joris et
verront d'un établissement bancaire
les gangsters exige de se faire conduire
à la salle des coffres
monsieur juriste refuse et parvient même
à s'échapper puis à prévenir la police
depuis on ne sait plus précisément ce
que veulent les malfaiteurs le contact
avec la police n'a pas été rompu et il
semble que les otages sont en bonne
santé selon divers témoignages le
commando est emmenée par philippe
delaire un français que monsieur
juristes auraient reconnu sur des photos
surnommé le roi de l'évasion de l'air
s'est échappé plusieurs fois de prison
en france et en belgique où il est
recherché pour meurtre
ainsi le 26 avril dernier filmé par un
amateur
ils sont spectaculairement les murs de
la maison d'arrêt 10h dans la loi en
juillet on reparle de philippe delaire
arrêté pour un simple contrôle routier
près de lyon il prend un gendarme en
otage
mais malgré un important dispositif de
recherches de l'air et ses complices
parviendront à s'évanouir dans la nature
après avoir relâché leur otage
la drogue problème majeur de nos
sociétés en 7 ème siècle quelques
chiffres tout d'abord sur la
consommation de drogues en france selon
une étude de l'inserm la consommation de
drogues chez les adolescents s'est
stabilisé depuis quatre ans dans notre
pays
pour autant ce n'est pas un phénomène
marginal il faut bien le reconnaître
un jeune sur 11 et concernés en france
les résultats complets de cette étude
seront rendus publics tout à l'heure sur
antenne 2 dans l'émission de jean marie
cavada la marche du siècle justement
consacré à la drogue mais voici un
aperçu des principaux résultats de cette
étude à la halle à 12 9 % des
adolescents ont touché à la drogue au
moins une fois mais seulement un jeune
sur deux va y regoûter
l'expérience de la drogue n'induit pas
nécessairement la répétition affirment
les auteurs de l'étude inserm qui
constate dans le même temps un tassement
du phénomène drogue dans la tranche des
11 20 ans le haschisch a été essayée par
six pour cent des jeunes les produisent
à inhaler comme la colla rustine par
environ 4% et les drogues dures héroïne
cocaïne ou lsd par moins de 2%
les seuls produits dont la consommation
augmente sont les médicaments plus de 2
% les ont utilisés pour se droguer
c'est peut-être là le signe de la
banalisation de la drogue
à moins qu'il s'agisse au contraire d'un
véritable sos lancé au monde des adultes
selon les auteurs de l'étude le contact
avec une drogue n'est pas un hasard
simplement l'expression d'un malaise
le nerf de la guerre on le sait fait
l'argent est bien dans la guerre contre
la drogue
là encore c'est l'argent fait en tout
cas la conviction des spécialistes
internationaux et c'est pourquoi par
exemple à paris aujourd'hui il y avait
une réunion d'experts d'une quinzaine de
pays au ministère des finances
leur objectif c'est lutter contre les
trafiquants en les empêchant de blanchir
l'argent de la drogue
c'est à dire en les empêchant de
remettre dans le circuit normal là des
banques
le produit de la vente de la drogue et
en matière d'argent de la drogue et bien
il ya un pays clé c'est bien sûr la
suisse avec ses coffres et ses banques
dominique tierces et christian leroux
sont allés enquêter dans ce pays
on y parle beaucoup en suisse de la
dépénalisation de la drogue
un pays paradoxal où parfois les jeunes
se shootent à une encablure des banques
qui font transiter cet argent
cet argent de la drogue reportage
l'endroit s'appelle place du kiosque
un bien joli nom pour un rendez vous
hors bilan celui des paumés qui révulse
ce temps la ville rares sont ceux qui
s'y promènent sans avoir quelque chose à
me faire ici l'occupation principale
consiste à se shooter
dealer et de jeunes qui effectuent
ouvertement le même rituel
on se pique on achète sa dose de coco
d'héroïne en plein centre de zurich
comme d'autres achètent du pain ou du
vin dans un supermarché les autorités
tolèrent contre leur gré cette
provocation
elle affiche par là même leur
impuissance dans le quartier des
affaires de la bahnhofstrasse la haute
finance feint d'ignorer l'urgence et la
gravité du mal
elle pourrait pourtant trouver un jour
ses propres enfants prises au piège les
ce monde là est à l'abri des regards et
dans les bureaux d'immeubles parfois
classés il participe au grand lessivage
de l'argent que l'on dit sale car le
secret bancaire est ici une institution
il existe en france une image célèbre
celle du mur d'argent bien le mur
d'argent et celui qui entoure les
coffres suisses
depuis quelques années on a vu à titre
individuel un certain nombre de
procureurs et des juges d'instruction de
suite bien enfourché le cheval de
bataille du secret bancaire suisse en
faire leur affaire et lutteurs bretons
le grand problème est la grande
expectative
est-ce que ça va durer car c'est bien la
pinière cité de certains enquêteurs et
l'acharnement de la presse qui ont
permis d'ébranler la forteresse par
millions de dollars l'argent de la
drogue s'est infiltré sur des comptes
insoupçonnable
complicité corruption passive ou active
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'état les
sommes blanchies sans colossal et les
experts ont du mal à les estimer en
suisse aucune loi n'interdit
l'importation de devises
nous en avons fait l'expérience tout à
fait légalement je pouvais déposé au
sein même de la zone de transit de
l'aéroport de zurich le contenu de mon
sac j'ai des coupures de 100 dollars
dans 500 dollars le sac de 100 dollars
les j'aimerais savoir si je peux me
réussit sur mon compte
à genève voilà et ce qui n'est possible
donc c'est possible de faire ça ici
est ce qu'il est possible d'acheter de
l'or ouais c'est possible aussi
et donc je vois qu'il ya pas de problème
donc d'accord pourquoi les trafiquants
organisés en véritable multinationale se
priverait-il de tous ces avantages la
suisse accueille à bras ouverts les
capitaux du monde entier et pour les
banquiers c'est bien connu l'argent n'a
pas d'odeur
ces transactions en soi ne put pas et
alors il faut pas seulement plaident les
personnes qui sont impliquées mais il
faudrait aussi savoir quelles sont leurs
activités il y aura toujours des
possibilités pour abuser un système
financier une fois que l'argent sale est
entré dans le cycle des virements je
pense alors totalement perdu l'aveu
d'impuissance éclaire un peu gênant pour
les autorités suisses qui envisage de
réformer leur code pénal
tous les financiers qui auraient recyclé
de l'argent sale et manqué de vigilance
pourrait être bientôt poursuivi
abelli donne dans la suisse italienne
un procureur n'entend pas poser les
armes laisser le champ libre à
l'international du crime
audrey coordonnées soit au niveau
de la magistrature des magistrats pour
donner pour que les données que se
trouve par exemple en allemagne puissent
est connu partout
mais jeudi davantage moi je dis il faut
déjà coordonné au niveau suisse parce
que notre système fédéraliste fsi que
chacun du travail dans son domaine dans
son secteur dans sa juridiction
sans beaucoup de coordination d'un coup
de balai il est certainement plus facile
de nettoyer les traces de drogues
parties quotidiennes de jeunes suisses
que de se donner les moyens de gagner la
guerre contre les trafiquants
à titre d'exemple sachez qu'il n'ya que
sept fonctionnaires de police à l'office
fédérale de lutte contre les stupéfiants
les contradictions du système
c'est à lire ici avec impudeur à berne
les hommes politiques ont tous les jours
ces images sous les yeux elles ont été
tournées à deux pas du palais fédéral
oui j'ajoute que la réunion d'experts
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure qui
s'est tenue à bercy aujourd'hui a eu
lieu dans le plus grand secret puisque
aucun communiqué n'a été publié
après en fait hervé brusini les
spécialistes ne savent pas très bien par
quel bout prendre ce problème de la
drogue
vous savez hervé en fait il essaie tout
simplement de le connaître ce phénomène
de l'argent de la drogue dans mieux
cerner l'ampleur on parle de 300
milliards de dollars pour en chiffrer le
montant dans l'économie mondiale cela
représente à peu près une fois et demie
le budget de la france mais ça n'est
qu'une estimation car traquer
précisément l'argent sale comme andy
relève d'un extraordinaire tour de force
ces fortunes sont on ne peut plus
diffuse un peu plus éparpillé des petits
bénéfices du dealer qui proposent ces
doses dans la rue jusqu aux énormes
profits du gros bonnets la complexité
des circuits de l'argent est sans égale
les narcotrafiquants sont passés maîtres
dans l'art du placement en bourse de la
création de sociétés écrans de la
compensation bancaire et tout cela coup
d'ordinateurs par delà les frontières
secteurs les plus insoupçonnables de
l'économie sont touchés
les experts qui étaient réunis à paris
ce matin d'ailleurs savent qu'ils ne
sont pas au bout de leurs surprises
au mois d'avril ils doivent remettre un
rapport qui fera l'état des lieux
l'inventaire des mesures adoptées mais
en cours de route deux obstacles
pourrait bien surgir la politique avec
les intérêts divergents des états et la
résistance des banques et ils ne
laisseront pas ainsi mettre à mal leur
secret professionnel merci à hervé du
rififi à l'a5 là
cinquième chaîne qui n'a jamais vraiment
réussi à décoller et depuis sa création
cette cinquième chaîne subit maintenant
de grosses turbulences
jérôme seydoux l'un des actionnaires
augmente son capital et s'associe à
berlusconi pour prendre le contrôle de
la 5
mais robert sans l'actuel patron ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille
il porte plainte au tribunal au fond ce
n'est qu'une bataille ordinaire du
secteur privé mais l'audiovisuel il est
peu habitué stéphane magnier portes
closes à l'a5 cet après-midi ou plutôt
entrouverte puisqu'on nous a autorisés à
filmer le hall d'entrée et c'est tout
interdiction de monter dans les étages
pour poser des questions ou connaître
les éventuels états d'âme d'un personnel
qui voit la bataille d'actionnaires se
déroulait bien au dessus de sa tête
robert hersant en tout cas obtenu un
sursis en portant plainte contre ses
partenaires du conseil d'administration
il leur reproche de ne pas avoir
respecté le droit de préemption
c'est à dire de ne pas l'avoir tenu
informé des tractations en cours pour
qu'ils puissent se porter acquéreur des
actions mises sur le marché c'est sur ce
point et sur ce point seulement que le
tribunal devra se prononcer mercredi
matin mais cela pourrait aboutir à la
mise sous séquestre d'une partie
importante du capital est donc bloquée
pour un bon moment plus changement de
majorité au sein du conseil
d'administration de la 5
en clair robert hersant resterait à la
tête de la 5 pour un bon moment encore
mais si le tribunal le déboute est alors
le conseil d'administration pourra avoir
lieu très vite le tandem seydoux
berlusconi pourrait prendre le pouvoir
si le csa donne son feu vert définitif
et cela se ferait sans doute avec la
bénédiction du gouvernement
très agacé par le non respect par la saq
de ses obligations en matière de
programmes
même si la raison première de tout ce
remue ménage est d'abord financière
les pertes de l'a5 s'élève à 1,7
milliard de francs
la france et l'iran améliorent leur
relation peu à peu après une période
très difficile chacun tente maintenant
de recoller les pots cassés
françois scherr le numéro deux de la
diplomatie française est à téhéran et
s'est entretenu avec monsieur velayati
le ministre des affaires étrangères
iranien
il tente l'un et l'autre de régler les
contentieux financier entre la france et
l'iran patricia kaas la conjoncture est
bonne
côté iranien on est demandeur la
priorité du nouvel homme fort de téhéran
rafsandjani est connu
priorité à la
de l'économie le pays a besoin de
devises et vite pour ne pas accentuer le
nombre de mécontents qui commencent à
demander des comptes
côté français le numéro deux du quai
d'orsay françois scherr a les coudées
plus franches que ses prédécesseurs
changement à la tête de l'iran pas
d'attentât en france à la suite de la
publication du livre de salman rushdie
et nécessité de rééquilibrer la
politique dans la région
le contentieux financier entre les deux
pays devraient donc se régler rapidement
la france devait aux iraniens à
milliards de dollars pour la centrale
nucléaire eurodif payé par le chat mais
non livré à ses successeurs
s'y ajoutent les intérêts côté français
on demande que soient soustraits de la
note
les dommages et intérêts d'une
entrepreneurs qui ont été lésés par le
non respect des engagements
un calendrier mensuel de discussions
vient d'être établi reste la sphère
nakache du nom de ce militant islamiste
emprisonné à perpétuité pour l'attentât
contre le premier ministre iranien
chapour bakhtiar
les iraniens disent que deux
gouvernements français leur ont promis
nakache contre les otages promesses non
tenues voyons maintenant d'autres
informations d'autres informations
importantes de ce lundi à commencer par
la reprise des relations diplomatiques
entre la hongrie et israël cela fait 22
ans que ces relations avaient été
rompues anne consigny
1967 c'était la guerre des six-jours la
hongrie suivant la lignée des pays du
bloc de l'est
rompu ses relations diplomatiques avec
israël aujourd'hui au moment où la
hongrie ouvre son rideau de fer moshe
arens ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères en visite à budapest signent
un protocole de reprise des relations
avec son homologue hongrois hosni
moubarak président égyptien reçoit
aujourd'hui au caire il craquera bing
juif israélien de la défense
il évoque la tenue d'élections dans les
territoires occupés un projet défendu il
ya deux jours au caire par yasser arafat
18 morts 20 blessés bilan encore
provisoire de l'effondrement d'un
immeuble la nuit dernière au sud de
beyrouth
à l'origine de cet effondrement deux
obus qui aurait provoqué l'explosion
d'un stock de munitions probablement
entreposés dans cet immeuble par le
hezbollah 40 km de bouchons au septième
jour de blocus de la frontière
italo-autrichienne du col du brenner et
routier italien protestent contre la
limitation des autorisations de transit
délivré par l'autriche limitation
réclamées par les écologistes
autrichiens qui trouve le trafic de
poids lourds trop important
le vaccin rer comme rougeole oreillons
rubéole sera désormais remboursée
c'est ce qu'annonce aujourd'hui le
ministère de la santé pour qui la
vaccination de masse reste la seule
prévention contre ces maladies parfois
dramatiques +0 15% de hausse à la bourse
de paris quant au dollar à paris fils se
stabilise en légère hausse au cours
officiel
ainsi france 65 30 aménager les rythmes
scolaires vaste sujet on en parle
toujours mais on ne le fait jamais ce
sera en tout cas le thème du magazine
comment ça va le magazine médical
présenté tout à l'heure vers 22h30 22h35
par henri sannier et le bon docteur
flaysakier c'est vrai que ce problème
des rythmes scolaires n'aboutit pas
alors qu'il suffirait de peu de chose
que chacun y mette un peu de bonne
volonté
par exemple cette école de
loire-atlantique à séverac c'est une
petite localité et bien là on a fait les
efforts et les résultats vous allez le
voir sont probants marie-françoise griot
aimé mayol reportage ce petit garçon a
bien tort de s'inquiéter la journée que
vont passer les élèves de l'école
maternelle et primaire de sévérac a été
organisé pour leur confort en fonction
de leur rythme particulier quand ils
arrivent vers 9 heures du matin il a
besoin d'être mis dans l'ambiance de
l'école
donc laissons le raconter un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé avant le temps
concrètement la journée type à sévérac
commence par une demi-heure de remise en
condition sous forme de conversation ou
de poésie en gros s'il ya un sens puis
vers 9h30 au moment où les enfants sont
au mieux de leur forme
on passe aux choses sérieuses français
et mathématiques
le tout entrecoupé de deux récréation
sait aussi qu'au niveau de la vigilance
il va devenir moins vigie
en fin de matinée vers 11 heures à peu
près en revanche on fait aussi que la
vigilance va redevenir importante vers
le milieu de l'après midi vers 15 heures
l'aménagement se fait au niveau de la
journée mais aussi de la semaine au
départ de constatation simple les
enfants n'étaient bons à rien le lundi
matin et le vendredi après midi
nous commencerons le lundi matin par
l'effectivité donc jousse par exemple la
piscine les enfants du cours élémentaire
pour la piscine dès lundi matin et le
vendredi après midi
nous terminons également donc par des
activités de sa blague ruelle où poésie
chant il ya qu'à ce mercredi matin ce
mercredi matin
mais ce n'est pas un simple report des
cours du samedi matin au mercredi matin
tous ces aménagements n'aurait pas été
possible sans le concours de la
municipalité dont dépendent notamment
les transports scolaires convaincre
monsieur le maire a été facile
une enseigne en cm2 mais l'école de
sévérac se défend d'être une école
pilote les aménagements on ya mis en
place sont conformes à la loi n'ont rien
coûté et sont donc à la portée de tous
les établissements en face aussi un
espoir formidable pour certains
handicapés le fait d'être amputé d'un
nombre n'empêche pas toujours de mener
une vie normale
la technique la plus moderne alliée à la
pratique du sport fait parfois des
miracles
voici l'histoire fabuleuse la jeune
américain qui avait été amputé d'un pied
jean ma mère denis soleure pour vite
très vite même et pourtant unijambiste
il porte le plus discrètement du monde
une prothèse à la jambe droite que de
nice honneur pour très vite personne
aujourd'hui ne peut le contester les
recorman du monde des handicapés sur 100
m dans le temps incroyable de 11
secondes et sept centièmes
une performance que bon nombre de
valider en virée de même que son titre
olympique acquis à séoul l'année
dernière de par son style et sa
technique il est au dessus du lot dans
sa catégorie sa supériorité s'explique
par l'utilisation d'une prothèse
révolutionnaire à base de graphite et de
carbone et dont la souplesse se
rapproche de la flexion cheville pied
mais il a tout de même fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour s'y adapter et
aujourd'hui à sa façon il est une star
il côtoie les stars le grand carl lewis
double champion olympique sur 100 m lui
produit conseils et encouragements
reconnaissance suprême de sa normalité
entre guillemets ce qui est formidable
c'est qu'il me prend pour un athlète de
haut niveau
le handicap après félix secondaire de
nice fait désormais profiter de son
expérience les autres sprinteurs
handicapés dennis aux leurs c'est un
athlète exemplaire
à l'endroit fermé journal comme
d'habitude un coup d'oeil rapide sur la
météo alors mon cher cabrol dites-moi
est-ce que cette chaleur à crever va
continuer bien mon cher claude cette
chaleur à crever ne pas continuer dans
la mesure où nous aurons tout de même un
zeste de fraîcheur c'est vrai
aujourd'hui il a fait très chaud entre
27 et 30 degrés quasiment les
températures estivales demain devront
supporter le passage d'un front
il est très étroits à l'avant dès orages
à l'arrière un petit brin de fraîcheur
donc vous respirez peut-être un petit
peu mieux comme beaucoup d'entre vous il
ne nous en dit pas plus il faut vous
écouter dans quelques minutes au milieu
de la pub
voilà j'ai encore à vous donner quelques
pronostics ceux du tiercé c'est le
tiercé donc qui se court demain c'est un
tiercé quinté + c'est le nouveau truc
alors donc c'est sur l'a7 à vincennes
donc c'est au trot voici les pronostics
de pierrette brès le 14 le sel le 8 le
18 le 7 le 10 le 11 le 6 pour le quinté
plus il faut trouver cinq chevaux pas
facile mais ça rapporte
alors donc je vous rappelle maintenant
les rendez vous de la soirée tout de
suite la marche du siège voulait dit sur
la drogue jean marie cavada
et puis à 22h30 magazine médical comment
ça va saigner flaysakier qui parle des
rythmes scolaires
et puis ensuite vers minuit la dernière
dix éditions il y aurait du journal
présenté par christian mary monod à
demain 20h bonne soirée sur antenne 2